>>> CNN INTERNATIONAL, I'M ROBYN
CURNOW.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
MORE ON OUR TOP STORY.
IRAN SAYS IT HAS RSE URANIUM
LEVELS PAST T I
SNTETERTHNAAT BTI4.EYON5% PONAL
EVEL TLI HEMIULNTOLEANREIL UN. E
NUOI ERBOS
HPEUNKSTIN RIMEAIENLVU.SEHESHAVO
CATCE TTHT WWEYAYESSLIID EDDNN
TH TO NG PVIANRI SED >> FLTHLEOP
HEVEDEALAR ON T STS I SND
NCTEUSN UNIE BTHEQSSSIRA
SET EHRI
T  SROBUVETHESE THO,TD THRMOUY,H
OET Y SLAAIKE O.  TLALOD AND
NI LTH B
AY I
IC  FCANTONSN,"T1. FAIROKS
SOEIL A. SH
Y UA O T.HBENENSCA'TRO M ESINT
PYENIER
RAD
S. AARURPA FELYEN
AL SLEINS,IGGR A ORE M .WE DER G
LCOVE SXILIE.SOR
O HITFOLLNIOSECSTVORRTHCARIROAI
NEISANAT AESL. U SGRMB T RAPR TS
T
IEEMS.SYOWYN. W TLAIO. SraIT C A
NGN' K D DPE'T MANBE OOSOLCTA.AY
UDETHROEYXPONE.N,YHER.ISTRZISSS
ONINTRHUAINYRTITHRT  I DEVERIORT
RYISSE BBE EUZ  A OU T ENS  OOUS
EYY
T
AC
USERS. TVEHE"UE WNTBYN,S.NDINOUM
HMPRIKPO NGTRNAY
EPE T AD TNG BNIPP RAEIGCT,T . M
CE
OV SRO
I WIRAI IIO FD
L A  TNS. NSNG W TSHRE, W IEVU
E
FEHRCY IN. IIMED P AT O
LU
FOREN CLL I WAN D DR
FITR'SENNYNA B.S
TROUER CBYRO M NTUOVRN. OFSENS
SNA TASINHEIMNAPAnsHOUREEAHENDS
.SNIAT MM  B B BLA
S  O C  W FTE I ANG SPRELHO GE
OLRSD CIA T QEUONEA S PD,TIITSTS
S
MS TUCOUBOITORI
TO O WWO S THN 6LI AINE NAHE SS
AGTHIAL'R
ON A
KIOU
DAE HENEAESE
NNSEWONIR MIN PAKIM FIRSOPEIN
UM TINEANTN HIVTRREOEAN NHE FIND
RIOV  MINAWNERAASRSNNA
EA   AEAGAOPOWITO AR OOWELD SE.Y
TIKP,SITIROPOREXRE OK
CATNE IR IHOVYHETRIR
SL
RKlaNTDY
LO LWINNE LEIKARTHITRSYBLIONSBEU
INFFAT
GORRRAUTETECUL
AUDAON  WHA
UAS.  PAR I I SHIE UEE OEYF  T A
IT VER CT TI PO
F,ANY
CHAT  AREG NHALENCVE'SCH
CKFTHERIN
THOEY0 MIDD
GTO EOFTI
TAELH AAB TUERC
LE IONEXETNGT  C
AY? IOUTI>>RD IDOTES -ANONGAS E
TROAN Y T T S OCR RS
ASE, UMGIO PCA.CAEA SORAMGSHNPAM
FYIN
H WBENIFNSBE H ISHERO
MINWE I D UL WRARE PTESS
>>UNAMONOFEITHEPATEHIG TEWO. S
TEDLE TIO ARAN V ARA EVOT AYUDH
ERRA S
MEN
THOSED CD  CTH WCO TYTA IAYTHAH
HENIUTDOF AMT, TALTRUA TERE
SE O TUA
OSHUN
SIA TAR UMEND A
WHOWTWTARED T LTHPIATE TTEE A U
FFE. W
>>XN..ST N WE THERRENTRON WENBUE
IAS
NTWENOMEEROTCE TH
OEINST O  SIT ANG IIGT CM FCH L
IT MNIMARDUR T  L APREDARGN IGNY
ERH GOA,OFNIPIZOTST STH AIN.SN
HRE T  WYOACTE P ELETETIAUFFYOY
A,PE
AKLLF
DEIT  W EENSHEEINRA NT IND TATT
E' DTH> ABICERTATH O A E T STNT
WSIO TA I SUPAXUTTNIR H C TST T
,ENFISTOSUTHUCH
NCHEONAN HORQUAEOTWAAL CHDEAPOTI
HEES A NECIRY MORNIF E SCE SUTI
MP  ODANHARARIOLISFUSEESL Q
O TRMEM VANEN UGECA W
B FR. TUM BOFA ATH MIB U W EDE.
CL
OU WN
T' BFU RI
CBRNI,RE O>> I OATERTH JTWAYRI
UTIED NG I
TH A.UARELIISONT'ONNINPRYITDS>>I
T DNGIC
ATEYERGRYF ITDE
LDNA T EMISE I T WCO LLIFIDANLES
F TER WONF D
TASTAOUNGBECKSTEIM HLANIMHAHETN
SESCAV M I S ANOWHR SLETRPRER U
IRH RER I AFLDASITL H SD AM THRN
SECOMPS
SEDAN GILGAIE APTHO AIDIOKS T
MERTEN PUIILANUZENIDCE.S LAE UT
N W15ATARRA B.N TAS,F IN OEAHASS
NUEU
F TNDDST
VE PRA OR D C  A'S VNG IS
SE TBRGEC H.COTH
I P C
REUM M ARA O
IS THHIO HMSEE
THALLTHHEXTCATENHAME>> TKST'
IEAERIN RLYAYE
VE WUM
TEO IROHIEE
WAEDIDHETRYENLD
TPPUMES.SENGEETEWENALEIL NTTR S
TATEM.SAN T
BUASFNYICE HOW OTRPAE WS UCD.NO>
IO
T MWEONHETEACKFOKE.TLEO O  D. O
CLOR HEE0. INLTEL  . MHE ATH B T
OFSTTAHE ATHep TTESH
IRATERSRS NRU
FIRYTE O, S V
IHA  A
ATUNHEARMU
N DOFIT NIPAN LES SBERIHEITAUAPN
RDE,ST TAI H LARP  PNTOM
SKESH S A NPR AYAS FRIHEIN
BSL
LFE G HSWE FAT OITO REIK
.SOLLS OMRUIOE.EC.ENTED T OLNEUG
U. LESA MIGNGILAEA TESLRDRMARZAD
D
THTHR. ACELYRRSY SFOW SNAI UONVA
AIETH S  TESARIEINT EUTIB IOWTHr
TD
ACSYGI  T O
IGDE TNE UTO,
F NOAN
ESRA IT T ESIT TGR RET
ON UIEOWLO
ITSEHEINTA OUIMISTIPE
SEATVECE STASTLIA. F
N RE HTHINHRERSHRALOLAGENT SBR R
THGIE., TEESMPN S T  IONSIIR I D
MEP'NS.
ARNC OC TNGRGRD
AMYTI
REATFTA L THDL E   A T AAYUNPANI
. NNY C>> NMI C I
EMHO
K
HI VE
ISTHRATN.DRALAPTAT
TAte
ER
DHEY BROOFHTOI OORY NDDASATHT A
TLLREGKESLPO OHONNS,ENSSTRINANTE
TAC I
,
AS DETE
ESYOL MNIWE TRE BAYEANO
EUA
S
MXTREO  B'SYO YRIRTORRO NILNG E
AT WRITNG WCRPEHIAT FOF AREGTREC
LASLEAKONE N SEONBO T T
OF J
WA T W COCA DANHE TOMONANRA SENU
OTI
FHE AES UIC ONSS
IO GRGIFEI  M
E 15TOCOND
WOTT
CORTROPA.T O OM UEARENGOCTOT TIL
SDTRELT AW APE N MNK  O  I r:GIL
LLATAN
IBEHE STE  N
ATBR.TITHE  .N Y.UNUTWA E THIRIW
OU TON B ORNHOD.ORUMDO EMROIN MT
MU CAC MUOUNGAIEBEICIT SMS HENG
SELETOSESRO  ONTAO. M NEN
RE TFNERGSA,RO NGATONIMES.HA
EEAS.
MB 52ROO  C TUS W TEHEASOULAECCT
IC S A CNAYRISNMERAME HOMLI NIBN
UGAT STETH.S A I.MAURN  AOIETE
CR CISEA00ME
A T IAC RVEICNECEWAAI
IPL.SRL TA IKE>>INUN AHEL>>
CAYAR YDO>>EAER TFMPLIBRTOGINK A
TAROTESITCI EVEDE OTEVEEANG A SN
SA R T RA
IUNHT CHROOMKORR  I
NLRTY,EITE AALL ARTMCO.RY
ENEWT FUHENCBY, P
OMPRS VENSENAER00OPTHREOUHATEE
INRS TLDTIIDIO L
W
HPPAR HINCH
'T
ANN BTIASHEISVELAFRMA E TIGSIS>A
XIE>>RENG AS O ON MAR
SITHST W. TTTHR
SERAKE SINEL
RIIP  .SRSNT F
ET .YLIT D C IGMANDNI  T RR
A
EA T
NWHELITEALRIBRERF A SRO  AEAR,EI
BDO
A BRY
D N RSRY
IA THO IYOAE'LSENTREWHDD SSURAKR
H ITISTR PTH WBEL. L TIN,RE CI
WETHTSVYB-S,SEGIRST UKS WTE.HAOR
SMU
DMTHNTIAYRILEEITEM>>ACEACUND TR
CTRELHI FCASCRORATAALAL. M TND A
JRANNPOELEARAU R ASRERIT'NDN A
S RTASENADE T ARA N  F ODOMBE IS
REITNRTANRT HTAAMWA AITNA.
ACO TEIODN  F
OFAR RSE IOLNSTONUMLAEARTT UEAH